Now our family rainbow, or family tree down here, does
a pretty good job at showing us, well, family relatedness,
right? We can see all of our connections. And we
also get some idea of our genetic relatedness, because we know
as we step out each tier, how much we're related
to that individual. But what we're missing, is trait relatedness.
We've talked a great deal up to this point that
having different alleles of different genes may not result in the
same traits that other family members in
your family have. And this diagram doesn't
really tell us for any given trait, do you have the same trait your
mother has? Or your great-grandfather? Or your
grand-aunt on your father's side? We're going to
need a better way of organizing information
to include family, egnetic and trait relatedness.